Geht's wieder?
Ich glaube, es geht wieder.
Ja.
Oder vorne zugeschlagen, Leute.
Oder vorne zugeschlagen.
Die haben gesagt, nope, jetzt wird nicht gestreamt.
Streamen overrated, outdated, cheap baited.
Geil.
Warte mal kurz, was gucken in meinen E-Mails.
Okay.
So.
Wieder am Start.
Oder vorne.
Geht's jetzt?
Hat's geruckelt nochmal, Leute?
In den letzten paar Minuten?
Gut, ich hab nix gemacht.
Man hat nur den Chat gesehen.
Da ruckelt natürlich auch nix.
So, also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Hier.
Bei der neuen Option für Stores.
Ach, man sagt jetzt Dollar.
Man sagt jetzt nicht Dollar-Blub.
Man sagt jetzt Dollar-Count oder so, ne?
Ist not a store with a subscribe method.
Aber wie macht man das denn jetzt?
Ach, man schreibt einfach nur.
Nur Blub-Count oder was?
Ah.
Okay, das kann das Autocomplete noch nicht.
Not a number.
Warum?
Muss es Const sein?
Warum ist es not a number?
Vielleicht kann man Plus-Plus jetzt nicht da drauf verwenden.
Weil Count ja ein Setter ist oder so.
Muss ich jetzt sagen Count.
Plus gleich 1 oder so?
Ne, äh, Moment.
JavaScript.
Geht das?
Ne, das funzt auch nicht.
Also, aber sowieso Count gleich 1 wird funktionieren.
Ja, das funzt.
Okay, das heißt, dann braucht man die lange Variante von.
Cancel.
Äh?
By the way, warum ist das überhaupt?
Was?
Warum ist das überhaupt undefined?
Und warum steht da nicht 1 drin?
Ich sag doch hier explizit create user state 1.
Ah.
Initial.
Punkt username.
Das ist ein Objekt, was der erwartet.
Also eigentlich will ich sowas hier haben.
Äh, jetzt funktioniert das auch.
Was das hier macht, check ich noch nicht so ganz.
Das wäre Objekte oder so.
Das brauchen wir an der Stelle.
Geht das jetzt mit plus plus?
Jetzt geht es auch mit plus plus.
Okay.
Gut.
Also das ist quasi jetzt der Store Ersatz.
Wir können jetzt mal kurz checken, ob das mit dem Store, ob das so funktioniert.
Denn wir gehen jetzt mal.
Wir zeigen das jetzt einfach mal nicht hier an, sondern zeigen das in unserer Kackel Component
an.
Ja.
Und die kriegt jetzt den, ja ja, den muss ich jetzt erst noch importieren.
Ja, Moment, wie greife ich denn jetzt von der anderen Komponente da drauf zu, weil da gibt
es ja Plupp gar nicht.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Kann ich einfach, kann ich einfach hier auf, also bei einem Store hätte ich jetzt gesagt
Dollar.
Aber das ist es ja nicht.
Moment, der hat Probleme, weil es die Datei nicht gibt.
Moin Michael.
Ja, das funktioniert zwar nicht, ja, beim Store hätte ich jetzt sowas davor gemacht,
aber das funktioniert ja jetzt nicht, aber ich meine einfach jetzt hier Kauen schreiben
wird es nicht tun, oder man muss das im Kontext setzen.
Ja, das ist das muss anders gehen.
Das musstest du bei einem Store auch nicht.
Du würdest gerne eine Web App erstellen, die keine dauerhafte Internetverbindung benötigt
und kannst alles verwenden dafür.
Oder?
Oder du meinst so Sachen wie Offline State und Sync und so, boah, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Du kannst das natürlich manuell machen, irgendwie in Local Store und so schreiben.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Gute Frage.
Nächste Frage habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du willst, du willst sowas haben, wie wenn du dann mal wieder online
gehst, dann die neuesten Sachen abholen, updaten und so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also damit bin ich auch nicht so ganz glücklich mit den Stores.
Wie es hier ist.
Mit dem Store Ersatz kann ja nicht sein, dass ich jedes Mal den Store irgendwie über Kontext
rum passen muss oder sowas.
Das hat mich schon komplett überzeugt.
Ja, wie gesagt mit Stores war das easy.
Die hast du einfach importiert und konzentriert darauf zugreifen.
Also so funktioniert das schon immer nett.
Und müssen wir mal weiter gucken.
Ich gehe mal davon aus.
Wie nennt sich das denn jetzt hier?
Svelte 5 Stores.
Guck mal was da drin ist.
Ich muss hier was dazu schreiben.
Ja Store.
Er hat noch hier irgendwie.
Old vs New Examples.
Gibt's da nix zu?
Cuntions vielleicht?
Store?
Da steht.
Da gibt's doch keine Docs dazu.
Checkout Component Party.
Wann soll das rauskommen?
Irgendwann 2024.
Doom Swap.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Irgendwann 2024.
Irgendwann dieses Jahr.
Mario danke für den Sub.
Ah nee, das war gestern.
Das war gestern.
Danke für den Sub.
Ah nee, das war gestern.
Hatte ich gesehen, aber trotzdem.
Pog.
Im Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, richtig.
Also ganz schlau werde ich da noch nicht raus.
Das muss ich mir mal bisschen näher angucken, wie man damit Stores gescheit ersetzen kann.
Was hat man sonst noch?
Form Inputs.
Gibt ja nen Unterschied.
Außer State, ich nicht.
Checkbox, Radiobutton.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Das muss man nicht.
Ach so, wenn man Standalone verwendet, Fetchdata, das muss man sich auch nicht angucken, Routerlink.
Okay, das war die Übersicht.
Also da, mit Store-Ersatz, das muss ich mir tatsächlich nochmal angucken.
Da bin ich so noch nicht ganz glücklich mit.
Also die Store-Syntax funktioniert ja so schon.
Keine Ahnung.
Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich muss jetzt was essen.
Wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ups.
Gibt es ein 4-Jahres...
Ich glaube, wir haben...
Nee.
Ich glaube, das Höchste, was es gibt, ist, glaube ich, der Goldkeks.
Ich müsste echt ein paar neue machen lassen.
Es sind Leute schon so lange dabei, teilweise.
Wird mal Zeit für neue Kekse.
Ekelst du eins?
Ja, du kannst gar nicht erwarten, ich weiß.
Magst du sagen, für den Sub?
Braucht man mal ein paar gute Ideen für...
Du kriegst dann das Wubbler.
Wubblers Cert...
Wubblers Certified Professional.
WCP bist du dann.
Das wird überall international hoch geratet.
Das Wubblers Zertifikat.
Also so viel haben wir jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich muss sagen,
nach meiner anfänglichen Skepsis, die ich hatte, als sie das hier im Artikel da rausgebracht haben,
muss ich sagen, ich finde fast alle Sachen nice.
Was?
Besser als was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Ich bin sogar versucht, mal zu sagen, wir bauen irgendwie ein kleines Beispiel,
wie so eine Mini-Beispiel-Webanwendung mal, mit so ein paar Komponenten und nicht wirklich...
Nicht wirklich viel Zeug drin, aber mal mit Svelte 5,
um mal wirklich sich die Unterschiede anzugucken.
Ja, blöd, dass der Stream abgekackt ist, so kurz vor Schluss.
Ich gehe jetzt aber was essen, Leute.
Ich bleibe nicht on dabei.
Ich kann einfach...
Irgend...
entspannter futtern, wenn Community-Gier nicht am Start ist dabei.
Und wir hören uns die Tage, Leute.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
Ziu.